the hidden moon is rising over forks
Washington and suddenly you shy away
from my body's warmth my muscles are
hard as I can make it but that's not a
not for you you want me to be cold and
hard like a moving marble statue the
only thing that you think you need is
the one thing that I can never be you
don't love because I'm not Edward Cullen
I can wear sparkly makeup and act all
brave and solemn but you can't help but
realize these are golden contacts in my
eyes so you think you can't be the one
and only girl for
only one man can protect me from her
plus a hundred years of investment made
him richer than God for a century he
saved his virginity for me and I know
all about that girl you scored with in
2003 he's the only man that I can't
resist and you can't convince me he does
not exist I can't love you cuz you're
not Edward Cullen you can wear sparkly
makeup and act all brave and solemn but
I can't help but realize those are
golden context in your eyes so you can
never be the one and only boy for me
it's so superficial that you love his
fancy cars but Edward Cullen also never
ever has to fart I hope someday his
child will rip its way out of your womb
give up now we can still be friends I'll
never fall in love with you the only
thing that I really leave is the one
thing that I can never be you don't love
me cuz I'm not
Edward Helen I can wear sparkly makeup
and act all brave and son
but you can't help but realize these are
golden contacts in your eyes so you can
never be the one and only before me